cycle sur le hezbollah en france et son
inquiétante progression
bonsoir j'ai smadja bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur de cabinet du maire de
nanterre vous avez cité u vous aussi
journaliste à l'humanité et vous avez
été aussi un proche collaborateur de
marie george buffet la ministre de la
jeunesse et les sports
le sport ça vous passionne et c'est
intéressant parce que c'est beaucoup de
connexions dans ce milieu et donc vous
allez pouvoir de décrypter un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé hier avec l'équipe de
france de football qui n'a pas mis un
genou à terre mais ça ce sera le
deuxième sujet de l'émission on commence
par l'actualité la plus immédiate si
vous le voulez bien
le masque c'est fini en tout cas ce sera
fini demain le premier ministre jean
castex l'a annoncé fini à l'extérieur et
en dehors des lieux de rassemblement
important
et puis le premier ministre a aussi
annoncé que le couvre-feu s'arrêtait
dimanche alors même qu'il était prévu
pour durer jusqu'à la fin du mois et
coûté le premier ministre
nous allons lever l'obligation générale
du port du masque un extérieur
deuxième évolution le couvre-feu à 23
heures qui devait vous le savez
s'appliquer jusqu'au 30 juin cessera de
s'appliquer à compter de ce dimanche
soit dix jours avant la date prévue
alors on va revenir sur l'éventuelle
dimension politique de cette annonce
mais d'un strict point de vue sanitaire
il était temps rachel benasque con qu'on
en termine avec ce port du masque ça
servait plus à rien le masque en
extérieur en effet il était temps en
fait ça n'aurait même jamais dû
commencer
il n'y a jamais eu de consensus
scientifique autour de ce risque là et
aucune étude à l'appui montre justement
à la fois une concentration ou une
contamination à l'extérieur or je n'ai
de côté bien sûr les rassemblements tels
que les marchés mais masque restera
obligatoire d'ailleurs pour les marchés
pour les files d'attentes et pour les
rassemblements aura un regroupement
beaucoup de gens mais là en effet
c'était peu sensé or on sait que dès
lors qu'une contrainte est forte elle
est difficilement applicable et
d'ailleurs elle ne l'était pas c'est à
dire que on pouvait voir dans l'espace
public des gens circuler sans qu'une
amende ne leur soit ne leur soit donnée
parce que parce que parce qu'en réalité
le sens n'apparaissait pas extrêmement
évident donc en effet il était temps de
mettre fin à cette mesure puisque une
mesure une règle en général dès lors
qu'elle n'est pas suivie de sanctions
quand elle n'est pas appliquée elle perd
toute sa valeur là le gouvernement en
fait suivant une espèce de principe de
précaution un petit peu instrumentalisée
à des fins politiques s'est dit comme
j'ai raté la question du masque en mars
avril dernier puis un début de campagne
de vaccination qui a été quelque peu
difficile c'était une manière pour lui
de s'inscrire un petit peu de montrer
qu'il était actif d'avoir une forme
d'action comme ça dans l'espace public
là il était temps de siffler la fin du
match
c'est aussi un constat c'est aussi le
constat c'est à dire que l'on peut voir
que depuis plusieurs jours voire
plusieurs semaines au fur et à mesure
que la l'épidémie baisse dans notre pays
de manière
est très sensible on peut voir quand
même que beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
gens ne portent plus le masque ou le
porte sous le menton où c'est
moyennement efficace voilà et donc donc
en fait le gouvernement se dit on va
être ridicule à continuer de vouloir
imposer cette mesure alors que il ya une
toute une partie de la population qui
est en train de s'en affranchir
et donc voilà on donc en fait on ne fait
que régulariser une pratique qui est
déjà largement largement engagé mais
évidemment c'est pas un hasard si ça si
ça vient aujourd'hui parce que parce que
bon il aurait pu attendre le 30 juin
pour le faire ou en même temps que le
couvre-feu
je pense que bon là on voit bien que il
ya eu une tentative de vouloir être
sympathique populaire de vouloir essayer
de caresser les la population dans le
sens du poil
on se dit qu à trois jours du premier
tour des élections régionales et
départementales
c'est sans doute pas plus mal bon je
pense que ça ne se noient absolument
aucun effet en terme en terme électoral
mais il est évident que si le
gouvernement a pris cette décision alors
même qu'il l'avait pas du tout laissé
entendre y compris jusqu'à hier ou
avant-hier on n'avait pas cette
perspective en tout cas pas aussi
rapidement et l'a visiblement on le fait
parce que il ya une échéance électorale
et qu'il faut essayer tous les moyens
sont bons quoi c'est aussi l'avis de nos
internautes en nous vous posons la
question sur twitter les mesures de fin
du port du masque et du couvre-feu
sont-elles plus politique que sanitaire
et vous ne répondez oui à 72% mesures
politiques
sûrement car ça mais terme en parlant ça
aurait dû être fait avant nous dit
nicole et puis il ya ce point de vue de
pierre aussi il n'aurait pas eu
d'élection proche on aurait encore
poireauter julien estime que emmanuel
macron essaie de redorer son blason
avant les élections de dimanche prochain
en premier lieu et aussi pour 2022 à je
ne sais pas si charles julien si les
électeurs s'en souviendront encore mais
après tout peut-être
et puis
e
ou qui nous dit tout le monde ou presque
se plaint de ces mesures et quand elles
sont enfin retirée on se plaint qu'il
soit purement politique
bah oui c'est ça les médias on a mauvais
esprit alors il ya quand même cette
remarque de clément sur laquelle
j'aimerais vous faire réagir en automne
avec la montée annuelle de l'aco vide et
nous redirons qu'on ait des mauvais
élèves et qu'il faut remettre le masque
c'est vrai que même s'il ya consensus
sur ce plateau il ya des médecins qui
considèrent que c'est pas forcément une
bonne idée d'enlever le masque écouter
l'avis de richard en chu c'est un
médecin généraliste il est membre du
syndicat mg france et lui dit attention
il reste un truc qui s'appelle le
variant delta et abandonner les mesures
de précaution c'est peut-être pas une
bonne idée
regardez ce variant delta il est en
train de monter de façon exponentielle
il n'est pas plus dangereux simplement
il se transmet beaucoup plus vite et
donc s'ils se transmet plus vite
il y aura plus de patients contaminés ce
sont des jeunes ils ne risquent rien
simplement au fur et à mesure ils
risquent beaucoup moins et mais il le
transmettent et il y aura de nouveaux
variants qui risque d'arriver donc moi
mon inquiétude c'est les futurs à rien
et donc il faudrait vraiment éteindre
cette épidémie et pour les peindre et
bien et on n'a pas le droit de se lâcher
complètement ou bien il faut qu'on soit
complètement vaccinés
c'est vrai que l'épidémie elle n'est pas
finie et peut-être que on symboliquement
on envoie le message que on n'a plus
besoin de prendre des précautions en
interne en supprimant l'obligation du
masque à l'extérieur l'idée c'était de
se débarrasser de toutes les mesures de
précaution notamment dans les espaces
clos
ça fait consensus grosso modo on est
plutôt bon élève
on a compris qu'il fallait le mettre en
intérieur que ce soit dans les
transports en commun dans les commerces
etc
maintenant encore une fois plus la
contrainte elle est forte plus les
difficilement tenable en effet il est
possible qu en automne alors ça dépendra
aussi de la la course au vaccin mais il
est possible qu'en automne lit une
augmentation il sera temps à ce moment
là de prendre des mesures éventuellement
des mesures adéquates je suis pas sûr
que ce soit le masque à l'extérieur mais
on verra
c'est là maintenant là les chiffres sont
plutôt positifs
aucune étude ne montre t une
contamination extérieure il fait chaud
c'est comme un critère qui a été assez
important on n'applique pas on ne met
pas généralement d'amande on ne
sanctionne pas les gens qui ne le
portent pas à l'extérieur ça fait quand
même beaucoup d'éléments pour pour
mettre un terme à une règle en fait
qu'il n'existe que sur le papier
j'ai également un sujet d'inquiétude
mais ce n'est pas liée au port du masque
par rapport à ce qui va se passer à
l'automne prochain
mon sujet d'inquiétude c'est la
vaccination c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
je peux vous dire pour le vivre sur le
terrain dans ma ville que on va on va
atteindre un plafond et le gouvernement
a annoncé aujourd'hui que son objectif
donc il a raccourci les délais pour la
deuxième injection
son objectif c'est 35 millions de
vaccinés avec les deux injections
la fin du mois d'août 35 millions la
population qui est âgé de plus de 18 en
france c'est 53 millions c'est à dire
que le delta il est énorme ça veut dire
qu'il y aura de 18 millions de français
de plus de 18 ans qui ne seront pas
vaccinés à la fin de l'été c'est à dire
au moment où le risque d'une reprise un
tiers une au moment où le risque d'une
reprise de l'épidémie il est réel et là
il ya un vrai problème et moi je pense
que le gouvernement a tort de ne pas
aborder maintenant clairement qui est un
sujet tabou absolu qui est celui de la
question de l'obligation de la
vaccination
je pense que cette question va venir il
va on va essayer moi je suis favorable
si c'est encore un de nanterre vous
croyez que les gens le l'accepterai on a
beaucoup parlé de l'acceptabilité de
toutes ces mesures
quand vous quand vous mettez au monde un
enfant et qu'il faut le vacciner sur la
polio le bcg et c'est vous le faites
c'est une obligation quand vous allez
voir quand vous voyagez en afrique et
qu'on vous dit qu'il vous faut vous
vacciner pour contre la fièvre jaune
pour pouvoir rentrer dans certains pays
d'afrique vous le faites
quel profil d'aider des gens dans votre
commune donc alors vous avez pas fait de
statistiques sur mon mail dont vous ne
vous sentez qui sont plutôt récent il ya
des gens tellement on va sur les marchés
et on propose des gens de s'inscrire
pour des rendez-vous parce qu'on sait
qu'il faut y aller qu'il faut pas
attendre
on y va donc les gens
voilà on leur propose de prendre des
rendez-vous et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un tiers un tiers
un tiers un tiers de gens qui nous dit
ah mais ça y est je suis vacciné un
tiers de gens qui hésitent et qui bon
finalement s'inscrivent parce qu'on
arrive à discuter et un tiers qui disent
non moi je ne veux pas me faire vacciner
et cela généralement en fait on voit
bien que derrière il ya l'idée bas
l'épidémie elle va s'arrêter elle n'a
pas besoin de moi pour s'arrêter
c'est à dire en gros si je ne me fais
pas vacciner il y aura suffisamment de
gens qui le seront pour que pour que
j'ai pas besoin de moi de me faire
vacciner
et ça c'est vraiment et c'est là où il
ya un problème puisque encore une fois
si on en croit ce que nous disent les
scientifiques là dessus il semble être
d'accord on nous dit que pour atteindre
le fameux taux d'immunité seuil
d'immunité qui fait que l'épidémie
elle s'arrêtera voilà eh bien il faut
qu'on soit à environ 80% de la
population adulte vacciner mais on en
est très loin aujourd'hui on en est très
loin et donc est ce qu est ce qu on peut
admettre que l'intérêt particulier à un
moment donné prime autant pas sur
l'intérêt général est-ce qu'on peut
admettre ça est-ce qu'on peut admettre
que l'intérêt particulier où la liberté
individuelle
cette liberté quelques je ne vois pas où
aller cette liberté la liberté sauf pour
des raisons médicales évidemment là
c'est autre chose
mais la liberté de ne pas me faire
vacciner avec comme conséquence le fait
que je vais je risque de maintenir la
société dans son ensemble dans un état
de crise économique de restriction de
non je ne vois pas où est la liberté
dans ce domaine et là je trouve que au
moins alors je j'admets qu'il peut
évidemment il peut y avoir d'aidé des
opinions contradictoires mais au moins
ouvrant le débat
abordons le là on a l'impression que
c'est un truc dont on ne veut pas parler
mais vous verrez qu'à l'automne ce débat
va venir
rachel me nasrin fait réagir sur une une
tribune
du professeur gilles pialoux qui est un
médecin qu'on a pas mal vus à la
télévision qui travaillaient à l'hôpital
tenon à paris 20e et qui écrit dans
l'express en parlant de la de la fin de
l'obligation du masque à l'extérieur et
dis attention
d'abord il ya les incertitudes quant à
l'efficacité vaccinale partant de
variants et puis il ya cet argument
qu'elle n'avait absolument pas pensé il
dit mais et les gens qui vont continuer
à porter le masque est ce qu'il n'y aura
pas une sorte de marquage social il dit
les les gens qui nous continuerons à
porter le mas sont les hypocondriaques
les gens qui sont pas vaccinés les anti
vaccins les gens qui sont émis nos
déprimé et donc il dire une forme de
nouvelles discriminations entre les gens
qui portent plus le masque ceux qui sont
obligés de le porter ça vous paraît un
un argument recevable ou pas moi je
trouve ça trop crédits nets arguments
pour vous dire donc ça m'intéressait
d'avoir votre poignet je vous rejoins ou
alors je ne comprends pas entièrement
alors les défensives accidents des
jarrets oui oui oui oui c'est court mais
c'est un peu le secret médical qui est
respectée quand tout le monde a le
masque ou pour les verts les anti pacs
ans je suis pas sûr qu ils voudront
garder à tout prix le savoir j'emploie
plus dubitative exactement ensuite mais
ensuite libre à chacun si certains on
vit ou de le garder parce que parce
qu'ils ne se sentent pas assez rassuré
pourquoi pas c'est que c'est un
mouvement je pense qu'il va prendre en
effet un petit peu de temps il serait il
ya supprimé le masque en extérieur il ya
deux mois ça se fasse plus tôt plutôt
bien alors il était aussi bien en avance
sur la campagne de vaccination
ensuite il des individus ont envie de de
le garder je vois pas trop quel serait
le problème concrètement quels combats
s'y habituer comme comme en asie où on
voit toute l'année des gens qui portent
le masque en permanence notamment dans
les emplois de services en contact avec
le public
il ya un internaute sur le site du
figaro qui vous répond sherjill façon
directe la vaccination chez les adultes
n'a jamais était obligatoire surtout que
le vaccin est en phase expérimentale
jusqu'en 2022 2020
c'est obligatoire alors c'est
obligatoire par exemple et ça c'est en
effet une question qu'on a un petit peu
abordée mais qu'on n'ose pas réellement
posé mettre à l'agenda
c'est celle des soignants on sait
aujourd'hui qu'un certain nombre de
soignants
même dans les ehpad ne veulent pas ne
souhaite pas puisque la vaccination est
ouvert depuis un certain temps ne
souhaite pas se faire vacciner
or même pour des infirmières avant même
de s'inscrire aller à l'école elles sont
obligées où ils sont obligés pour les
infirmiers de d'être vacciné pour un
certain nombre contre un certain nombre
de maladies
oui et on peut le dire vous l'avait
annoncé indiqué d'ailleurs que quand on
vend un certain nombre de destinations à
l'étranger on est obligé de se faire
vacciner
je reviens un instant sur l'autre mesure
annoncée par le premier ministre
la suppression du couvre-feu à 23 heures
est-ce que ça va avoir un impact concret
donc dans une ville comme nanterre où ça
va éviter les incidents
oui je pense que les incidents qu'on a
vu qu'on a connu la semaine dernière à
paris week-end dernier place des
invalides
et bien franchement il vaut mieux parce
que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une espèce de moment de soulagement
de libération les jeunes veulent sortir
ils veulent faire la fête ils veulent se
retrouver et bon ben voila et donc c'est
vrai que ça n'avait plus aucun sens et
c'était de plus en plus difficile à le
faire appliquer ce couvre-feu
quand on n'est pas capable de faire
appliquer une mesure il vaut mieux il
vaut mieux arrêter quoi parce que là
c'était ça moi je pense que c'est
vraiment une très bonne chose
en plus si on avait maintenu le
couvre-feu à 23 heures on aurait fait
comment pour les bureaux de vote et pour
la des annonces des résultats aux
élections parce que là avec deux
scrutins avec deux scrutins et avec le
dépouillement de deux élections on va
aller bien au delà de 23 heures
donc franchement non ça n'avait plus
aucun intérêt d'avoir ce couvre-feu est
bon ils l'ont fait ils ont ils ont
anticipé le 30 juin tant mieux tant
mieux autre sujet que nous voulions
aborder avec vous il y a eu hier le
premier match de l'équipe de france dans
le cadre de l'euro qui s'est soldée vous
le savez sûrement par une victoire 1 à 0
contre l'allemagne
en revanche si la victoire était bien au
rendez vous il y avait quelque chose
d'autre qui n'a pas été c'était
cet engagement qui avait semble-t-il
pris l'équipe nationale de mettre un
genou à terre avant le début du match en
hommage à georges floyd vous avez ce cet
américain ce noir américain